who are you a fan of right now because  you're young I feel like you kind of  I've always kind of been hit to the the  next wave of [ __ ] next wave man I've  been listening a lot of Spanish music  lately  trying to get your Spanish [ __ ] up I  love um there's an artist her name is uh  tokisha she's so hard  I don't know that is so she's super hard  I just saw Bad Bunny though and that  [ __ ] was crazy yeah Bad Bunny at the  [ __ ] sofa man Bad Bunny that's what  I'm saying the Spanish Market is just so  big you know he did the [ __ ] football  arena football two nights in a row it's  insane yeah yeah when you see that [ __ ]  like are you like would you ever do like  a full Spanish album like some reggaeton  [ __ ] I would yeah to be honest yeah I  would yeah yeah  the market is it's insane right now yeah  like it's killing it